at this altitude I can run flat out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by audible which I've used for years I
love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by Rolf pots which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books the
graveyard book bag debonding or more
than 180,000 audio programs so that
could be a book that could be a magazine
that could be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy go to audible.com
forward slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs
is a great partner for creating and
growing your business it's a one-stop
shop for all of your graphic design
needs whether that's a logo website
business card or anything else I use
99designs to get book cover prototypes
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one New York Times
bestseller and I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99designs com
/if Tim and right now my listeners you
guys will get a free $99 upgrade on your
first design that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim check it out
hello my friend Lea little McGuire this
is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm very
excited about this one folks have wanted
to do it for a long time took about a
year year and a half to set up and of
course every episode is my job to try to
deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out the perspectives habits
routines favorite books etc that make
them as good at what they do as they are
this episode we have Marc Andreessen @p
marca p.m. a RCA on Twitter he is a
legendary figure here in Silicon Valley
and indeed worldwide even in the
epicenter of tech it's hard to find a
more fascinating icon Marc co-created
the highly influential mosaic internet
browser the first widely used graphical
web browser he also co-founded Netscape
which later sold to AOL for 4.2 billion
with ABI and then co-founder loud cloud
which sold as Opsware to Hewlett Packard
for 1.6 billion he is considered one of
the founding fathers of the modern
Internet this all makes him one of the
few humans ever to create software
categories used by more than a billion
people also one of the few whose
established multiple billion-dollar
companies he's now a co-founder and
general partner of the venture capital
firm andreessen horowitz where he's
quickly become one of the most
influential and dominant tech investors
in the world now I want to try to keep
this short but it's hard and I think
you'll enjoy at least what I'm about to
read so we refer to an email in this
conversation and our conversation took
place at the Sand Hill Road
offices of injuries and Horowitz we
refer to an email from mark to Ben
Horowitz and Exchange and this is how it
reads because we don't dig into it in
the interview this is page 13 in the
hard thing about hard things by Ben
Horner which which is a great book to
Marc Andreessen this is after a media
interview where Ben felt that Mark
disclosed the company's strategy
prematurely to Marc Andreessen from ben
horowitz subject launch I guess we're
not going to wait until the fifth to
launch the strategy period signed Ben
within 15 minutes I this has been
Seve the following reply to ben horowitz
CC bunch of folks from marc andreessen
subject launch apparently you do not
understand how serious this situation is
we are getting killed killed killed out
there our current product is radically
worse than the competition we've had
nothing to say for months as a result
we've lost over three billion dollars in
market capitalization we are now in
danger of losing the entire company and
it's all server products management's
fault
next time do the [ __ ] interview
yourself [ __ ] you comma mark so we get
into some really fun stuff in this
interview that I don't think mark has
discussed in many places we talk about
his epic debate versus Peter Thiel we
talk about all the usual questions
favorite book cities gifted to other
people favorite documentaries movies
morning rituals what he would put on a
billboard etc talk about rules for
investing what he does in partner
meetings to make people to defend ideas
or propose ideas we talk about AI we
talk about the future of Bitcoin drones
who to watch we talk about what he would
teach in a 9th or 10th grade class
advice to his younger self what he
misses about the mid 90s internet and
how he might recreate it how he thinks
about or handles FOMO it goes on and on
we really had an extremely detailed rich
conversation and I hope you enjoy it and
please do say hi to mark he's very
active on Twitter at P marca p.m. AR CA
without further ado please enjoy
mark welcome to the show thanks Tim I am
so thrilled to be here I've been hoping
to make this happen for quite some time
and I figured we'll just jump into it so
the the first question is strong
opinions loosely held you're associated
with that expression can you explain
what that means
yes so it's kind of a mentality it's a
mentality around how to start a company
for sure and it's a mentality of how to
invest for sure and I think it's a
mentality that's probably helpful in a
lot of other areas of life and so it's
kind of this I'm drawn to paradoxes I'm
drawn to kind of you know is that the
philosophical term it's like a thesis
antithesis synthesis kind of thing and
so there's a lot of people why people
develop a very strong theories and then
the problem is they care of them too far
because there's always there's a
countervailing theories right so you
know the end kind of thing and so strong
view so strong views is very important
right so most people go through life and
basically never develop strong views on
things or specifically go along and
basically buy into the consensus and so
one of the things I think you want to
look for is both the founder and as an
investor is you want to look for things
that are out of consensus right so you
know something very much opposed to the
conventional wisdom which sounds easy
you know hard to do but you want to try
to do it and then if you're gonna start
a company around that if you're gonna
invest in that you know you better have
strong conviction because you're making
a very big bet of time or or money or
both the problem is okay it's a strong
view great okay what happens when the
world changes right what happens when
like something else happens right and it
basically the way right the way the
world works kind of in business and
investing and other places is just when
you think you have everything figured
out that everything changes right the
sort of system of walls and things
happen and so what do you do what are
you doing the world changes and and
they're what you just see everywhere I
think in the world and everywhere in
business ever investing are people just
hate changing their minds people just
like it's just like people get locker
you know you just see politics all the
time as well people just get locked into
a point of view on things and then you
get this all this you've all these
biases like confirmation bias where
people feel like they have to get well
it's the thing in politics for a
flip-flopping write as V is bad right
right right
politician flip flops is viewed as bad
and sort of week and probably probably
evil actually it's interesting if you
talk to the world's best hedge fund
managers they're the exact opposite they
love changing their mind
like like I'm one of the few people who
openly admit I love spending time with
hedge fund managers I think they're
awesome I think they're I feel similar
they're fantastic people and they are
they're the most open-minded people I
know it because and they they love when
you tell them if they're wrong they get
all excited their eyes light up and
they're like oh why why do you think
that and they're genuinely interested
because if if you're right and they're
wrong they will change their minds and
they will you know their hedge fund
managers he'll literally reverse the
trade Delfy they were along in a company
they'll flip around go for it on it
they're totally fine with that and
that's how it works and so so when I
care away from that is it's it's the
weakly held part which is convicted
convicted convicted new facts change
right but but it's a paradox right or
it's it's a tension because those are
those are ants that you know it's
determination coupled with flexibility
like they're they're they're
antithetical what you see in the startup
world is sort of these two kinds of
advice then that expressed this and
there are people who with a straight
face will get both of these forms of
advice without ever acknowledging that
they're in conflict right one of which
is fail fast right you know you want to
fail fast like it's gonna be great to
fail you won't discover what's wrong you
want to fail and do something different
and then the other is you have to be
determined and you can't give up okay
like how do you possibly reconcile those
and my view of that is that's that's
where you get to strong fuels weakly
help so how do you advise in in that
particular example for instance or
assess which tact founders or a company
should take potentially because you you
look at some examples let's just say
uber or something like that where the
model as it began is very much similar
to where it is now then you have other
companies let's say like Twitter or
others where they pivot into a goldmine
effectively and then I mean then
obviously other things have to be later
on top of that to make it successful
long term but having been in the valley
now myself 15 16 years you see a lot of
people who change their mind almost too
frequently that's right with in
[Music]
consequential facts perhaps how do you
think about advising a company that's
struggling as to whether they should
stay the course or pivot as they would
say yeah yeah so we have we see both
cases we see both we see both cases both
failure cases we see companies that are
just there almost late fail fast thing
is frankly completely out of hand and
and I'm old fashioned where I come from
people like to succeed like it
great I'd like to say like we did before
this worked like we didn't have like
when I was in when I was a founder when
I would first started out we didn't have
the word pivot right we didn't we didn't
have a fancy word for it we just called
it [ __ ] up like I'm old-fashioned on
this like I like to succeed I think
succeeding should be the goal not
failing and certainly not failing faster
or slower any other form of failing so
so I get really kind of cranked up about
this but but we do see companies that
literally every time we meet every time
I meet them they pivoted like and so
every time I meet them they're off to
something new and and they're dude sighs
I don't like watching a rabbit go
through a maze or something they're just
never kid they're never gonna converging
anything because they're never gonna put
the time in to fit into actually
figuring it out and getting it right but
then you you do see the other case and
this is what the that's where the fail
fast thing came from is you do see their
case you see people who just absolutely
are determined that it will just pound
their head against the same wall for
years and years and years and years and
is at a certain and you admire them for
the determination and then at a certain
point it just becomes the obstinance
right and then you're just as in some
point it becomes self-destructiveness it
becomes Don Quixote you're just tilting
against windmills you know kind of
arbitrarily and so those are poles we do
see behavior at the poles you know the
question you're asking is of course the
key question which was like okay what's
what's in the middle how do you know and
and frankly I don't think there's an
answer to that I think that's the answer
is judgment I think I think that's the
test busy there's a there's a couple key
tests for four founders or for that
matter for investors in these kinds of
decisions I think that's one of the
really core tests is you know do you
fundamentally have the judgment to be
able to make that call knowing by the
way that either either way it could be a
big mistake like you know nobody's gonna
tell you you're not gonna get any
confirmation for anybody that oh yeah
you made the right call like that you're
not you're not gonna realize like if you
change and then succeed it's all great
but by the way you might have to see if
it's the old thing even better if you
change and fail you know you'll never
know whether the old thing would have
worked like you know they cut the
counterfactual like you know science I
call it the counterfactual you never
know the counterfactual the way my brain
is what I'm always thinking in terms of
the counterfactual is I'm always
thinking in terms of the way things
could have been right the world evolved
in a certain way kind of as a
consequence of people making all these
decisions on the fly people could have
very easily made a different set of
decisions the world could have ended up
in a very different place and so the
idea that you're ever gonna know the
consequence of your decision I think is
probably a fallacy what the alternative
would have been right I get the relative
relative result of your decision and so
III just think you basically have to
fall back on judgment and you have to
fall back on some sense of the
intangible
and when you're looking to say stress
test ideas and if we look at it in say
the case of a partner meeting here so
you mentioned hedge fund managers and
I've read a profile of Ray Dalio at one
point I guess it's Bridgewater Capital
and he talked about his his meetings and
how they stress test ideas and and how
people need to defend ideas how does a
good partner meeting go if someone say
proposes I was gonna say a trade an
investment an investment it is a
substantial investment what then happens
from that point to a yes or a no
decision so we don't get the hedge fund
manager can reverse himself hedge fund
manager bad trade in the next day you
can turn around and take the opposite
trade we we don't get to do that right
so when we invest it's with it's knowing
that we're in for 10 plus years
basically as our assumption so it's in
suit and by the way we make an
investment decision it's a it's a
commitment of dollars it's also a
commitment of somebody's time and and by
the way the organization's time and
bandwidth and there's only so much of
that and then the other thing we have in
venture is when we make a decision we
then become committed to that company in
that category and so we can't invest in
their competitors including by the way
their competitors who don't even exist
yet - oh they can you know for example
the investors in Friendster we're more
more likely than not completely on not
only maybe unwilling but also unable to
investment Facebook when they came along
because they were conflicted because the
founder Friendster would have said you
know you can't you can invest in a
competitive company and so so our
decisions are big decisions and they
have serious consequences for the future
of the firm so on the one hand it's very
important to us to have a full
discussion and get all the facts on the
table and really kind of vet these
things out on the other hand we're
trying to preserve we're trying to
preserve the contrarian ISM of kind of
at the core of what we do the the the
strong not consensus views we're trying
to be able to invest in the things that
really are unusual and odd that other
people are taking seriously and one of
our theories about venture capital is
that so everybody thinks like investing
it's like you either make a good
investment or bad investment I actually
think that's not the big issue I think
the issue at least your metric apples
whether you make a good investment or a
great investment and I think good is the
enemy of great we see many companies
that are just fine and that are you know
yep you know founders are good and the
market seems good and the product seems
good the customers kind of like it and
they got
revenue and it's kind of all fine but
those companies tend to never go
anywhere and then every once in a while
we'll see these companies that just have
some extremely strong strengths some
extremely kind of you know special
wonderful thing going on that by the way
may have all kinds of problems and
issues but there's something at the core
of what it is that's really special and
magical and those are the ones that we
want to do we're trying to do is
basically stock our portfolio with just
investments like that and so to capture
that you can't have you know it be very
easy in a conversation about the
weaknesses is something to beat the idea
to death and you never invest and so the
the rule that we have and then and then
you would only invest in that contest
this once you'd only invest in two very
good ones as opposed to the great ones
and then you would fail as a firm so so
we have to kind of we have to do getting
both things at the same time we have to
we have to try really hard to encourage
the strong non-consensus thinking but
also have the full discussion to make
sure that we really stress test that
thinking so the way we do it is
basically each of our GPS has the
ability to pull the trigger on a deal
without a vote or without consensus and
and this what we say as if the person
closest to the deal has a very strong
degree a positive you know commitment
enthusiasm about it then we should do
that investment even if everybody else
in the room thinks this is the stupidest
thing they've ever heard of however you
don't get to just go do that yourself
completely on your own without stress
testing your own thinking and so it's
the responsibility of everybody else in
the room to stress test the thinking and
if necessary we actually create it we
create a red team right we'll actually
formally create sort of the
countervailing force and will designate
some set of people to counter argue the
other side it's like a debate team it's
yeah basically right and then and then
and then the way that we try to you know
this is fraught with like there's all
kinds of ways this can go wrong because
like what if I bring in a deal or what
if members in a deal or what you know
versus the new person bringing a deal or
whatever and so what ben and i try to do
is we we do this to each other right and
so whenever he brings in a deal like i
just beat the show right just like yeah
and i think it's the best idea I've ever
heard of and I was just like trash the
crap out of it right and try to get
everybody else to pile on and then at
the end of it if he's still pounding the
table saying no no this is the thing
then we all say okay we're all you know
we're all in we're all behind you right
and then and then it's an it's a it's an
agree it's a disagree and commit you
know kind of culture by the way he does
the same thing to me right and so we've
it's the torture test what are some of
the keys to fighting well in I think it
seems key to many different types of
chips personal business or otherwise the
ability to sign conflict resolved or
just fight well and then make up so it
seems like you and Ben have not my words
but like fought like cats and dogs but
you always kind of get over it we prefer
old married couple old married couple I
there is a story I don't know if it's
accurate about Netscape early days
something related to an interview with
the journalist do you know the story I'm
talking about it's in Ben's book okay
so right that's okay here we go is there
anything the email you're about to
reference all right so could you could
you could you describe this for people
who are unfamiliar I really think that
for that you got a review let's just say
we started out our relationship with
vigorous disagreement and we've
continued that to this day and but how
do you this is a family podcast I don't
want to use it all the bad words book
the hard thing about hard things it's in
the book and I'll put it in the show
notes the how do you I mean you has got
off to a very aggressive start how did
you identify that Ben was someone worth
having it those types of disputes with
that there was a value in in what he
brought to the table as opposed to just
another person that you were butting
heads with who is not worth keeping at
the table so honestly there were there
were three if there were three things so
one is he would he would talk back to me
so he would like argue right back at me
I wouldn't just go to the theater all
over like he would argue right back and
a lot of a lot of what you see this if
you just observe a lot of companies over
time or investment firms or whatever you
know everything you know there's there's
a temptation everything must to become a
hierarchy and then the people always
repetitions about speaking truth to
power and a lot of what I've always
found that really sort of wise the smart
leaders are trying to do is they're
trying to actually find the people in
the organization who will actually talk
back it's actually no it's one of the
ways to really get ahead you know
there's certain organizations where the
way to get ahead is to talk back to the
leadership right that's how you get
noticed by the way there are other
organizations where that doesn't work at
all
and I would recommend getting out of
those as fast as possible we try to be
at least been and I want this
organization to be one where people will
actually speak truth to power and and
argue back at us just like anybody else
and so which is why he and I argue so
much is because we want to set the set
the model
that's not the precedent so that was
once he would talk back to me - is he
was often if not always right and I
wouldn't say always just cuz nobody is
but like he was very smart and very
clear thinking and then the third thing
is I saw something early in him that he
was just amazing working with people
which is not something I think has ever
been necessarily true of me but he was
just like watching him in front of a
group of people was just routinely
magical in terms of how he could get
people how he could communicate with
people in a very clear way how he could
be very fact-based but he could really
make people feel you know kind of in a
really fundamental way and so that
combination you know made it clear that
he was somebody very special so we
mentioned Ben's book which is one of a
handful of books that many many of the
best operators bounders I know in
Silicon Valley routinely reference there
are a handful that come to mind aside
from that four steps to the Epiphany I
guess would be one this one here that
was right in the lobby of your office
high output management with the new
foreword by Ben Horowitz is another
which went out of print and then came
back into print because it became a bit
of a cult classic in here in Silicon
Valley are there any books that you
would prescribe to say it would be
entrepreneur coming out of college just
to give them to increase the likelihood
of them succeeding are there any other
books that come to mind yeah so high
output management it's one of a negros
books it's the best book on management
ever written he wrote another book
called only the paranoid survive which
is one of my favorite topics and so that
is also a very good book we recommend
Ben's book is good I think Peter Thiel's
book is soft recommending and a zero to
one and then there's a bunch you know
there's a bunch of others there's a
bunch of others that are good really
though I think where I got a lot of my
education from was history reading
history and so I would go back like I
would go back and read rather than
reading a lot more about the
contemporaries I would go back and read
about Edison I would go back and read
about Ford rockefeller JP Morgan I just
heard I don't maybe it's just me but
like I find the period of kind of called
1870 to 1920 1930 really interesting so
you guys heard of the arrival of many of
the technologies that kind of built the
world that we live in today disruptive
period yeah and history's I was saying
history
like I didn't really study history
college or anything but if in history is
this weird thing where the way that
you're taught history like in school
like in high school you know is like
it's it's all these legendary people and
they're kind of all the Olympians the
founding fathers and these great
generals or whatever and it's like
they've you know I got the names you got
the dates and they did these amazing
things and they're kind of these great
like and they feel like unrelatable like
any like you couldn't possibly like to
even at least where I come from even
think that you could have ever have
anything in common with these people was
just like a non it's not something I've
ever heard anybody like they're like
that you know the pantheon of kind of
the legendary people who have lived and
I just found like with the bat they're
really well written biographies they get
you inside the heads of what it was like
to be Walt Disney at age 20 right or
what it was like to be you know I don't
know Carnegie Mellon or Ford or what it
was like to be you know for that matter
William Randolph Hearst or you know
these you know people we've all heard of
like the really good bad rumors are
really good at getting inside the head
of what it was like to be them then
before they became right before they
became the people who ultimately made
another into the history books and and
honestly a lot of stuff like a lot of
things have changed but a lot of things
haven't changed like people haven't
changed a bit
and so you always find like in those
histories you can always kind of see ok
that personality type like yep I know
you know 13 people like that you know
and so I I find that there's actually a
lot more to template against and a lot
more to kind of think about then people
give people kind of give history credit
for oh definitely I mean I had Cyrus the
Great recommend to me Angus had seen a
fun and people don't change I mean you
see the same archetype she's like oh
that's Bob my coworker he does the same
thing and the biography mentioned made
me think of Walter Isaacson's book on
Ben Franklin who is always sort of
untouchable in my mind and but it
included all of his foibles and
challenges and self-doubt and it really
humanized it in a way that actually made
me aspire to do bigger things if you
wanted to get someone hooked on
biographies is there any particular book
you would recommend oh there's a bunch
the Walt Disney biography I'll just
mention it because it's a great are one
of our founders Brian Chesky the founder
of Airbnb is sort of Walt Disney is his
hero
and so he's gotten even more deeply to
that so author Neil gobbler who's
written the best biography on Walt
Disney and it's a phenomenal book I
actually like another one I really like
coming
kind of left field but there's a Charles
Schultz is the grater yeah peanuts the
but that Schulz biography is amazing and
basically the case that he makes is that
he basically makes the case biographer
makes the case that peanuts was the
longest continuous work of American art
ever made it was a sixty year art
project with deep foundations in
American history and psychology and
philosophy and through and it was a
reflection of the life you know the
person who made it and and of course it
was also a great peanuts is a great
entrepreneurial accomplishment because
you know is this very personal thing but
at the same time it became this gigantic
business success it's I think that one
is great The Wizard of Menlo Park is a
great biography of Edison and Edison is
very much Edison was kind of proto
Silicon Valley in a lot of ways and I
think he's really interesting to his his
his record of sustained innovation in
many many different areas and how he
then went out to try to commercialize
things good news is we are much better
at the commercialization part now that
the people were in those days we know
how to build the companies much better
now but the pace you know he would just
routinely invent things like the
phonograph like just it's just obvious
right to him yeah and so and he did that
you know for decades he was a fountain
of innovation and I it's a very
inspiring story the Netscape story we
touched on it very briefly and there
many places people can read about that
so I don't want to take up too much time
but on a related note I wanted to ask is
there anything you miss about mid-90s
Internet oh yes and what would it be
yeah so when I got to the valley in
1993-1994 I thought I had missed the
whole thing because I thought the PC I
had studied on study the history and I
said I used all this stuff and I thought
you know the PC I knew I know Apple and
Microsoft up in Seattle the Intel down
here and then all these great you know
I'll do build the big software companies
at the time you know Novell will notice
all these companies the game cuddy a the
gaming companies idea the great PC
companies had gotten built in the 70s
and 80s right and by the 90s inside by
the time the nineties arrived like it
was the PC was done like it was it was
finished and like you could go buy one
and it was great but like it was done
and in fact the overwhelming mood in the
valley when I arrived was
it was done like the the PC was done and
by the way the valley was probably done
because there was nothing else to do and
then there was this moment where I and
I'll you know various people and then
more people and then more people for
whatever reason it was kind of like
we've really wrapped her heads around
the implication of the Internet which
today seems obvious but at the time was
a very contrarian when I got to Silicon
Valley if you had said the Internet will
become a mainstream consumer medium that
three billion people are going to use
worldwide for all forms of human
activity you would have been left out
like you would have been
institutionalized here like people would
have laughed at you
and so as we figured that out then what
happened was it was like okay new front
here right it is part of that goes back
to the kind of history thing like you
know for a long time the development of
like you know the United States the new
frontier was whatever was further west
right and then eventually they got all
the way to California and then they have
the gold rush and like and then there
was a famous thing you know services
kind of theme in American history is the
closing of the frontier like there's a
theme of like every Western right that
every revisionist Western that gets made
is like there's no word friend here you
know the radicals can't go any further
west they just build drown in the ocean
so instead what we have where we have
kind of virtual frontiers we have
intellectual frontiers right or we have
creative frontiers or we have
entrepreneurial frontiers technological
frontiers and and so the internet kind
of represented the opening of a new
frontier and once we recognized that it
was like ah brand-new and then at that
point and that was where all the
enthusiasm came from because it was that
point of like okay if that's gonna
happen then you know what what do we
have to do and at that point right the
list becomes very exciting like we have
to do ecommerce we have to do online
publishing we have to do transactions we
have to do you know social networking we
have to do auctions we have to do write
all of the big franchise companies that
came out you know the next you know 10
15 we have to do search right all the
ideas kind of immediately materialized
and then people we know is off to the
races
is there anything comparable right now
for you so I think in my view there
always is the thing is these things look
like cults and fringe activities until
they break mainstream and so for me it's
not I mean so like for example the
mobile rush in the last 10 you know
basically since the release of the
iPhone the mobile rush qualified for
this the social networking rush kind of
post Facebook qualified for this and
those are kind of known and well
understood and it's just straight
entrepreneurial opportunities probably
you know generally kind of reaching some
level of saturation
right
slight digression we don't foreclose the
possibility but there will be another
mobile killer app or another social
killer app but it's getting harder and
harder and harder because more and more
people have figured out that you can do
these things and then the winners have
now got very established right one of
the ways I think about it is to have a
nut you know so you know if you first
you have Facebook and then you have
Twitter and then Instagram I know you
have snapchat and those all became big
winners okay now what would it take to
make the fifth one well it's got a
there's only so many icons in the home
screen of the phone right the fifth one
has to knock something off nest and
knock one of the other ones off and so
it's become as these markets saturate
because more of a zero-sum game or even
even smart phones you know smart
smartphone you smart phones a giant
industry but like unit volumes globally
are now expanding it like single digit
percentages and so the smartphone
industry is becoming one that's mostly
become people competing directly with
each other not not creating new things
and so we would say like those
opportunities those businesses are
gigantic and those companies will get
much bigger but there's not as much
entrepreneurial opportunity the
opportunity is more likely to be in the
areas that people think are cult and
fringe will be some examples we call
this what we go our test on this what
are the Nerds do on nights and weekends
their day job like the day job is that
work at Oracle or work at you know I
work at salesforce.com or Adobe or Apple
or Intel or one of these companies or
I'm or not or I'm just I work an
insurance company right we're gonna Bank
or whatever or I'm a student whatever
that's fine they go they go do whatever
they need to do to make a living it's
the question is like what's the hobby
what's the thing on the weekends so then
things get really interesting right so
then you look at like things like
cryptocurrency Bitcoin you look at
things like a lot of the new advances
there's a whole the whole area of kind
of help hacking you know quantified self
it's a very interesting new area there's
food you know there's kind of you've
actually been been part of the catalyst
for this but there's this whole kind of
area of like scientific food and food
hacking that's emerging
there is a revolution actually happening
I think in robotics because robotics
robotics has finally become something
tractable where people can do it at home
there's AI deep learning is right on the
tipping point you can now down as a
hobbyist you can now download this thing
called tensorflow from google interflow
tensorflow and which is a deep learning
framework
it's a framework for doing a is in the
field of AI it's a for how computers can
kind of deal with the real world and do
things like self-driving cars or you
know self right you know cell flying
drones or all these things
this is technology it was so at five
years ago it didn't really work two
years ago you would have had to have
been an employee at one of three or four
big companies to have access this
technology and then Google just open
sourced it and so now anybody in the
world can download it run it on their
own computer so all of a sudden like AI
is like a tractable thing that you can
just have on your own laptop and you can
build you can build new things on top of
it you can build you want to build a bot
you can build a bot you want to build a
cell tray we back to found a read back
to founder who'd literally built himself
his own self-driving car I read about it
right George and by the way you should
you should interview but like literally
like one guy can now build a cell for
having car right ten years ago this is
like a DARPA funded like Grand Challenge
like research project five years ago
this is a you know team of a thousand at
Google and now it's George right and so
that that's an example of the kind of
thing where it just looks like it's
gonna tip and then you know there's one
George today there will be a thousand
George's tomorrow do you think the
dangers of AI that some people talk
about are overblown completely 100
percent yes can you elaborate all that
many things I worry about the machines
rising up and killing us Luddite fallacy
it's not actually its various related
it's it's it's related to the Luddite
fallacy it's sharply related it's it's
the it's the it's the it's the
Promethean fallacy there's something
deep-seated in human psychology where we
are always going to invent the thing
that's going to kill us and at one point
or we're gonna we're gonna unlock
fundamentally ran I like the power of
the gods right it goes back to the
Promethean myth it's like the it's like
it's it's almost like the concept
originally sin it's like fire right the
big the big moral that Promethean
vessels like fire fire is the thing that
enabled human civilization is also the
thing that's gonna burn everything down
and kill us all right and so this is
very deeply embedded in our in our
psychology Frankenstein Frankenstein the
subtitle of Frankenstein of the novel
the subtitle was the modern Prometheus
right it was directed Frankenstein was a
reinterpretation of the Promethean myth
except in this case it was literally the
monster that was stitched together and
then brought back to life through an
unholy literally unholy science and then
there was there's even a religious
versions of it then in in Jewish
literature there's a concept of the
column which is the the the creature
made out of mud that the the rise rise
up out of it that's real life they got
us a horse or something to kill all the
enemies and then come back and then they
kill kills all the people who created it
right so this is very kind of core
John Henry I said it's the steel-driving
man right John Henry's the famous it's a
song or the sort of story about the
railroad worker and there's the machine
that can like can can hammer in the
railroad spikes faster than a human can
and John Henry its famous showdown
between him and the Machine and of
course he wins and then drops dead of
heart attack right and it's critical in
the myth that he drops dead of a heart
attack right cuz technology has to get
its revenge and so it's just that
projected forward and the reason I'm so
confident on this is because it's just
every single era of technological
advance this has always been the
response there's always been this line
of thinking and then it turns out it's a
tool it's a technology it's a tool it's
something that helps us do things in a
better way it's overwhelmingly to the
benefit of mankind and then we wonder
why everybody got so worked up over it
so if we if we put aside the existential
threat piece you know the summoning of
the demon conversations we've got that
aside entirely how would you answer
someone who who worries about job
displacement of AI and because they're
there some think reasonably smart people
who we are very fearful of what will
happen to society when people are are
massively displaced how would you
encourage them to think about that yeah
so let's crystallize the concern so the
World Economic Forum came out with this
this thing last year that kind of made a
pretty a lot of people out they said
there'll be five million jobs destroyed
in the next by 2020 by AI right so let's
let's run the numbers on that so that
sounds like a lot of jobs like that's a
lot of people that sounds like a lot of
jobs so then you look at the American
economy just this year 2016 and we don't
quite have this AI think working yet so
we can't blame what I'm about to say on
AI this year the American economy will
destroy 21 million jobs and create about
twenty four and a half million jobs for
a net ad of about three and a half
million jobs this is about the pace run
and that's this year right and so we
will destroy in the next three months we
will destroy more jobs than the World
Economic Forum projected will be screwed
destroyed by AI over the next five years
why don't people know this why is this
not obvious because whenever you read
news stories about job growth it's
always the numbers quoted are always net
numbers so last month 200,000 jobs 232
and a 50,000 jobs got created and so
those are net jobs nobody ever reports
the gross numbers the gross numbers are
either go best numbers we destroyed more
than 5 million jobs a quarter and we
more than six million jobs a quarter
basically quarter-on-quarter out and so
one is people just dramatically
underestimate the size and complexity
and churn in the American economy as it
currently exists another example would
be there's about it turns out there's
about five million people who drive
professionally in the US and so one of
the questions with like self-driving
cars right is where this what's gonna
happen the truck drivers in the taxi
drivers and everything everything else
again five million jobs we can read a
play we read a play every every quarter
we agree to play five million people
like this is not in the scope and scheme
of the American economy it's it's it's a
totally doable thing the other thing
that people don't appreciate and
understand I find my Boeing which is
would you would you guess based on
everything that people say would you
guess if the rate of job creation
disruption American economy is rising
over time or falling over time oh this
seems like a test and bound to fail ah I
don't have an informed opinion well you
would you would get I think most people
would guess that it's rising right the
view would be technologies having ever
greater impact right and so and it
changed feels like it's accelerating
right it's a big theme in the political
seasons it feels like the world's kind
of getting away from us technology's
getting away from us trades getting away
from us you know something is you know
basically dramatic changes are happening
that are historically unprecedented
right it's kind of the feeling mm-hmm so
almost everybody believes give you do
polling this almost everybody but it's
definitely the perception being created
right almost everybody believes that
change is increasing changes changed
accelerate actually turns out in the
American economy the reverse is
happening the rate of both job
destruction and creation are falling and
have been falling for decades have been
for like over the last 50 years they're
not dramatic lines down but they're
basically very slow lines down so
basically what's been happening is in in
fact every year the American economy
gets less dynamic right and and you
might say oh that's good because that
means that you'll have stability that
means people won't have to change jobs
all that stuff I would argue that's bad
because what that means is we're not
creating enough opportunity right and if
we're thinking about the future I think
we want to think about opportunity we
want to think about what we're gonna be
able to do in the future and we want to
think about what our kids are gonna be
able to do in the future right what will
be the new the new fields the new
Sciences the new forms of art the new
industries the new businesses the new
companies the new jobs that will get
created right every job that we all have
and everybody listening this podcast has
got created as a consequence of the
process of change right which is very
bad but has been very positive too
literally everybody on planet earth like
this is the
been very very positive changes in terms
of increase in human welfare and
opportunity and so the idea of living in
a world where change is becoming less
rapid which is what's actually happening
to me is it to me that would be the
problem like we should we should want
more change we should want but which one
more change because we should want more
advances because we should want more
opportunity to get created we should
want more products and services in our
lives we should want more industries
created we should want you know more
medical advances we should want more
advances in art and science in every
other field of human activity and we
basically whatever it is we have to
fight to get that as opposed to what
everybody thinks which is we have to
fight fight to prevent that what's the
smartest way to fight to get that if you
were willing to go into politics when
you run for often when you run for
office I will help you put your platform
together short of that I think the thing
to do I mean I think that the valley
view and I guess my view is you know do
what do what you can to directly
contribute to it right and so do it you
can do it you can to either either try
to create the new things try to create
the new products create the new the new
again art science technology products
what consumer goods create new things
create businesses around those things
right create companies or for that
matter by the way nonprofits like create
organizations or models that can let
things scale so that they can touch more
people and then you know a big part of
our role is fund them fund them and
support them and help and help enable
them and train them and get them up and
running you mentioned for instance when
you first got to the valley there was a
feeling on the part of many people that
it's done yeah PCs are finished I missed
the boat kid now in the venture capital
world there's a term used fairly often
FOMO fear of missing out how do you
think about or handle FOMO yourself yeah
mostly we just fall right for it
probably does total suckers for so the
way we describe so so fear of missing
out where's your missing out comes from
it's it's like it's clear and visible
signs that something is happening you're
not a part of right and so it's not FOMO
something that hasn't happened yet it's
almost something that's clearly
obviously happening so which which for
those people not in in the tech
investment world comes in in a concrete
form just as Anna is it may be Monday an
example
like an email from a founder hey we
would love to squeeze you in we're over
committed so and so and so and so is in
can you get us docs by tomorrow if
you're interested blah right I mean
there's a lot of sort of halt cortisol
driven emergencies some of which may be
real many of which are illusions yeah
yeah and so the thing is and so I guess
there's kind of there's kind of you know
there's kind of a couple ways to handle
it one is you just like you one of is
you view that as a sign of success like
you view that as like what it appears to
be which was like okay the train is
leaving the station and do I want to be
on the trainer or not that strikes
everybody is like so clearly wrong like
that must be wrong like that that must
be just foolish behavior which is why
it's been encapsulated into this term
called FOMO it's kind of designed you
know designed it's not scary like that
that must be a stupid thing you know a
lot of people will at least say that
what they try to do then is kind of take
the cynical kind of counter you know
theory which is like okay then by
definition those are probably bad ideas
because you're probably getting played
are you probably a sucker kind of you
know along for though the latest scam
and so the opportunities past or if it
was a good opportunity why would you be
asked to participate in it and then you
go to the other side the other cynical
side of the pole which is like okay now
I'm I'm not I'm not and there are
certain VCS who do this by the way I'm
not never gonna invest in anything hot
because it's gonna have that
characteristics so I'm gonna i'm elina
best of things that are hot the
uncrowded trade yeah yeah the thing that
nobody else is interested in right and
you know sort of a it's for old
companies they call that value investing
you know for new companies we just call
that you know cold sectors it's just an
area in which nobody is interested and
and so and you know by the way like I
don't think that that's I don't think in
any way that's a dumb conclusion and
there are investors who do that and it
works very well for them my personal
preference what I try to get us to do
around here is to just eliminate this as
a variable altogether and literally just
like not think about it and so like if
it's urgent we have to invest tomorrow
and then if it's you know they may or
may not never be able to raise money in
five years when I try to get us to do is
just ignore that part entirely basically
just take that out for on both sides
both the hot and the cold just take it
all out and then and then try to get to
the try to get to the actual thing right
try to get to that yet so what what is
yet really this specific company right
doing this specific thing with a
specific technology these specific
people at the specific time what is that
thing and let's make our own evaluation
of that thing independent of whether
it's hot or cold and then if it makes
sense we'll investment if it doesn't we
don't but we won't
factor in whether it's hot or cold now
the challenge we've actually worked on
this over time roughly on average the
things that are hot are priced somewhere
between two to four X higher than the
things that are cold at the extreme from
cold is called the hottest hot is about
4x right and so in in in investing terms
if it's super hot it's could be 40 per
year if it's super cold it's temporary
and for the same quality right for the
same fundamental quality level and a big
part of our answer is okay fine like
it's fine if we're gonna invest will
invest our market terms if the market
terms are 10 because it's cold we'll
invest there for market or 40 because
it's hot we'll invest there but we've
made our own decision about whether you
invest so we just try to strip it away
got it very easy to say easy to say hard
to do yeah the are there any particular
investors outside of venture capital who
impress you yeah so I spend most of my
night studying other investors either
study the people we can start the people
we compete with and collaborate with
very closely I also I particularly study
the value investors on the completely
other side of the spectrum and it's a
it's a fascinating and I've gotten to
know some of them directly it's a
fascinating kind of thing it was sort of
Warren Buffett as the archetype but also
there's now he knows a lot of famous
value investors Seth Klarman and a bunch
of others that have kind of you know
written books and the kind of built-ins
okay yeah yeah this whole kind of theory
of value investing that goes back to Ben
Graham in the nineteen in the 1920's
1930's and so there's this whole world
of value investing and on the one hand
there's no overlap between the worlds
because I like to say like basically
anything we're on Buffett's worth
willing to invest in we run screaming in
the other direction and vice versa
right and that's as it should be but
basically everything he invested like
Heinz ketchup right and the reason you
invest in Heinz ketchup is because
people have been eating Heinz ketchup on
hamburgers for a hundred years and
therefore the best guess would be that
they're gonna continue to eat Heinz
ketchup for the next hundred years
we weren't screaming from that because
like you're not gonna listen See's candy
no no absolutely not furthermore I'm and
I'll you know every time I hear a story
like See's candy I want to go find the
new white side of it you know super food
candy company it's gonna blow them right
out of the water right so like we're
wired completely opposite in that sense
basically he's betting against change
we're bet we're betting for change and
and that's a very very big like when he
makes a mistake it's because something
changes he didn't expect when we make a
mistake is because something
doesn't change right that we that we
thought would and so they could not be
more different in that way but what both
schools have in common is an orientation
towards I would say original thinking of
really being able to kind of going back
to the previous conversation willing to
really view things as they are as
opposed to what everybody says about
them or the way they're believed to be
like the value investors always talking
about like getting to the core of the
truth of what's actually happening in
the business and then the other is
long-term it's the only other place
value investor value investing is the
only other place in the market anymore
where you can find long-term investors
like Buffett will actually invest in a
company and he will hold it for 40 years
and that does not happen you know
elsewhere in the market it's only the
deep value guys who will do that it's
funny that at the extremes they have
that in common yeah that's right if you
were talking about creating opportunity
if if you decided to close a chapter on
your your career as a venture capitalist
a funder of ideas a catalyst and you had
to teach class so let's just say ninth
grade or freshman year in college 50
students what would you teach I would be
highly inclined towards teaching people
how to build things there's a book I've
actually never read but I love the title
what's smart people should build things
I do like the title I almost don't want
to read the book because I'm after that
title almost everything else anything it
says is gonna be a letdown but the
titles absolutely brilliant it's one of
my two favorite titles what's the second
second with Steve Martin I have read
this one Steve Martin's autobiography is
a fantastic book oh my life standing up
or how much Danny huh but actually I'm
sorry it's not the title of the book
it's called my life standing up as a
title but the main lesson of the book he
says the key to success is quote be so
good they can't ignore you right inside
and I think it's just basically if you
just have those two principles like if
smart people should make things and be
so good they can't ignore you like
that's a pretty good way to like that's
a pretty good way to orient the
autobiography is amazing also just
decided I listen to the audiobook the
Steve Steve Martin audio but yeah I mean
he's a comedy genius for more than that
the level it's like the Schultz thing
it's like the level of thoughtfulness
that he put in how he constructed his
career like nothing about his career is
an accident which I thought was as fast
anyway so I think would be how to make
things and by the way I don't
necessarily even just mean you software
in your computer programs about how to
make things more broadly and so how to
make you know again it goes back to
how to make you know how to make new art
how to make new science how to make new
technology how to make a new company how
teach that I think projects
I can't hands-on projects so you would
have say an art assignment you would
have a science / engineering assignment
of some type yeah yeah you have an
objective you'd have a you know you'd be
trying to construct something it
actually turns out one of the reasons
what computer science has advanced so
fast in the last you know 30 years is
because people can make new things on
computers without anybody's permission
and so you know it was a suffer well do
that but you know people can also write
book so that anybody's permission and
they can also write music without
anybody's permission and they can also
start companies mostly without anybody's
permission in most industries and so
it's basically just anywhere where you
can actually where you can actually
yourself create something new make
something new and then I find you know
I'm actually a little vary a little bit
from folks like Elon Musk on this like I
find making something new there for sure
there's part of it but everybody wants
to say is its creativity and so
therefore it's like you want to do
something new have an original idea but
but again that that makes people feel
like it's a it's a it's an unattainable
thing it's like how how am i how how am
I possibly going to come up with a new
idea in a field and where people have
been working in it for 100 or 200 years
like it just seems implausible so I also
find and I think the great artists and
the great scientists and the great
business people often have this in
common it just goes back to history
which is okay for whatever is you can
make learn about how things got made in
the past and get inside the heads of the
people who made things in the past and
what they were actually like and then
realized that actually they're not that
different than you like if the time they
got started they kind of just like you
Steve Jobs Steve Steve Jobs had a great
he said one of his his I think in his
commencement famous commencement speech
she said everything and everything in
the world around you was made by
somebody who's no smarter than you were
than you are right and so there's
nothing stopping any of the rest of us
from doing the same thing mm-hmm and so
I think that that would probably be what
I would try to do maybe a boring left
turn but I'm interested to ask and that
is what are the companies or who are the
people you're watching most closely in
AI drones and cryptocurrency yeah so I'm
very proud of we have a bunch of we have
a bunch of companies that we put our
like to say we're conflict of interest
or put your money where your mouth is we
have both we have lived up to both
principles so we have to drone companies
that I think are
tacular so err where was our first round
investment commercial drones which turns
out is gonna be just a giant market for
in industries oil and gas and insurance
and all kinds of all kinds of
implications but the one that people are
going to see I think in in in in their
day-to-day lives is gonna be more the
other one which is called sky deal which
is the company company way back and
doing autonomous consumer drones and
there's gonna be a very big advance in
what you can do it the kind of hobbyist
level what is an autonomous consumer
drone do whatever you tell it so they
haven't really they haven't rolled out
the product yet so I don't want to spoil
too much as a surprise but it's
basically it's it's a drone that can
fully fly itself it doesn't there's no
it doesn't require remote control and so
they can be given assignments and it
will go carry out those assignments and
it can fly through you can fly through
tree branches it can fly through power
lines it can fly through underground
parking garages without any collisions
it can just be compiled itself which is
if you've tried flying any of the
current drones they don't work that way
hard to do yes it's exercising how
quickly you crash it and so like that
that technology is about to tip and
become very widely usable and so that
that's very exciting so there's that I'm
sorry to interrupt after commercial
drones for insurance yeah so fringe so
be an example yeah residential insurance
residential insurance you get you get an
insurance inspector you're a new
construction you're remodeling or
building a new house and there's you
know you're gonna get the insurance
companies gonna insure it they do an
inspection the inspection involves you
know a person climbing up on the roof
and hopefully not falling off right and
taking a bunch of notes on a clipboard
and writing up a bunch of stuff and like
it's actually turns out to be a pretty
like it's a fairly dangerous job or
another example cell tower inspection oh
there's all these cell towers or so no
30,000 or something cell towers in the
u.s. they only need inspected inspection
literally is a dude on cables right and
these some of these are big towers and
then you get to like oil and gas like
you get you a drilling rig you got to
inspect that thing okay you know try
climbing up to the top of an oil and gas
rig right like these are very these are
these are these are dangerous thanks
lethal professor right these are these
are yeah and so if you could but what if
you could wait if you could just fly the
drone like what if you could literally
do the entire thing by air right what if
the inspector just rolled up to the
house and just took the drone out of the
back seat and just launched up in the
air and the drone
flies a pattern about the house takes
comprehensive 2d photographs of
everything and then creates a 3d
representation from the 2d photographs
which you can now do and then does all
the recognition elevations everything
materials figures everything out and
then the guys literally the you know the
inspectors like sitting in the driveway
in the car you know with air
conditioning on like in no danger safe
and sound
yeah yeah and so that kind of thing
there's another I'll give you another
this nobody's doing this yet but
somebody's going to so if you're if
you're a cop if you're cop on the beat
2:00 in the morning and you get a call
that there's a convenience store and
somebody's broke in the convenience
store you have to go do the check the
check involves going and saying whether
that you know the lights and all this
stuff in broken glass but you also have
to check the roof and check in the roof
is actually a very important thing
because if there's a bad guy and they
saw the cops coming they might have
climbed up on the roof and they might
have a gun and they might shoot at you
and so you got to go clear the roof and
so what do you do you get your
flashlight and your gun and you climb
the ladder and you poke your head up and
you hope that nobody's on the roof hope
no one plays whack-a-mole with your head
with it yes revolver yes exactly right
and so what would be that what would be
what could we do to help that what how
about how about every every police car
have a drone in the backseat and you
just you get to the thing and from a
safe distance you launch the drone and
the drone does an infrared camera sweep
right of the roof right before you even
walk up to the thing right and by the
way like if there's a bad guy on the
roof like what if the drone recognize
this like okay there's a person on the
roof and what if the drone locks onto
that person and then just basically
follows that person wherever they go and
they rabbit you know they run they run
for it and the drone is like right there
ten feet above following them the entire
time right so all of a sudden like just
the job of beat cop becomes a lot safer
mm-hmm and so that in this by the way
even goes back to the question you asked
which is like is an AI isn't AI threat
it's like no no like this is a case the
way those drones are gonna work is with
those are the power bi yeah those yeah
deep this is all based on deep learning
this is this new technology this new way
it's the same technology by the way that
was just used in that go in the
immigrant and the famous now go thing
where the Google hey I beat the you
think of an imposter yeah it's the same
technology and it's just gonna use for
it's gonna use for drones and it's gonna
be these are gonna be things in our
lives that we are just gonna be able to
rely on to be able to make our lives
safer and better and we're just going to
take them completely for granted and
we're gonna work in combination with
them and we're gonna be really glad we
have them and we're gonna be completely
unwilling to go back to a world where we
doesn't have them and it's just gonna be
obvious it's just
we have to get it but if we have to get
this stuff in people's hands before they
can they can really I think really fully
see it what do most people not
understand about cryptocurrency
I think it's just such well so a couple
things so this will not come as a
surprise to you I thought I understood
it and I really didn't um money gets
people really cranked up the entire
concept of money is probably the single
I don't know maybe after god it's like
the single most emotionally loaded
concept that we have in humanity like
money just because money makes people
mad under any circumstances on any topic
related to money right and it's just
because I think it's just because it's
such something that we all rely on and
it's something that we always think is
being you know like there's always a
sense of unfairness and so money gets
people really cranked up and so I think
that the they're sort of the idea of
cryptocurrency and blockchain and this
kind of new idea of distributed trust in
the internet and then there is this
application of that technology which is
a very fundamental application which is
a you know a new kind of money I think
most people are unable to just simply
objectively dispassionately look at the
mechanics of how it works
without almost getting preemptively
upset like just angry like how dare the
Nerds come up with some new form of
money like this has got to be like their
it's got to be something wrong with this
right and I will now attempt to find you
know the 30 possible things that could
be wrong with this until I find one that
basically proves that this can't
possibly work because obviously it
violates the laws of nature and
government and you know whatever
whatever and like somehow I'm gonna come
out on the wrong side of this like
people just get and by the way I'm not
even just talking about like regular
people I'm also talking like bank CEOs
just are furious like you bring up
Bitcoin and they're just like they just
get really upset and I'm like you know
did you get upset about your new toaster
like it's just a technology like it's
just a thing and you're gonna you can
study it and you can learn about it and
you can think about it and you'll either
conclude it's good or not but like it's
not gonna bite you like it's just a
thing right and so like the way I look
at it it goes back to like it's just a
thing it's just it we now have this idea
of cryptocurrency it's a it's a
fundamentally new and very important
idea we now have this ability to have
this new kind of currency based on top
you know everybody's had 18,000 theories
why it's not possibly gonna work bitcoin
is still working today exactly the same
as it worked last year and the year
before that year before that system is
completed by all the noise and all the
stuff and all the crashes and this and
that neither thing like it just
continues to work it just is like it's
becoming
you're coming like air or water it just
is you like it or hate it it just is and
so anyway we're still very excited we're
very excited and we're actually well we
are gonna continue to make new
investments against it other of your
current investments or non investments
so there are particular companies that
youth you think are breaking new ground
or doing interesting things in crypto
yeah so well so I mean coin bases are
sort of our big but most people have has
a company most people have heard of its
kind of the easiest way to buy and sell
Bitcoin and they have a whole bunch of
stuff they're doing and then we have
this company 21 which a really brilliant
founder Balaji Sreenivasan who was a
issue was a partner he seems to be a
very very very smart guy and he has he
has the he has the highest output per
minute of new ideas of anybody I've ever
met in my life and I by the way I mean
output per minute oh it's I've been in a
few dinners with him and it's hilarious
to just watch the outpouring after
especially after you know one or two
glasses of wine it's it's astonishing
he's like an emissary he's like an
Edison kind of character it's just it's
just literally thousands of ideas and
then it's whatever percentage of the
ideas that he can personally get to
write and then he'll give the other
ideas to everybody else and then wonder
why they're not pursuing them because
often a good question and then the next
time you meet him he'll have a thousand
new ideas and so his his company he's
people can read about it if they want
but it's done a bunch of interesting
things he has a whole additional set of
ideas he's pursuing now I had a long I
went to this thing up north and I drove
back and I was on the phone with him for
two hours you know the middle of the
night driving in on the freeway Balaji
in my ear you know idea number 38 I was
like this it could be worse use of time
that's a good food for thought the food
for thought what what advice would you
give to mark the twenty-something at
Netscape and you can pick the time you
know I've never even thought I've never
for a moment even thought about that I
don't do so the thing I don't I don't do
replace well goes this history like I
don't do replays wellness I like the
question I'll never answer is what would
you do what would you what would you
have done differently had you known X
and I never ever play that game because
if that you never you didn't know X
right and so fever every read does at
the Elvis Cole novels the
yeah the great crime novelist Michael
Crais this is not what Elvis calls this
kind of postmodern la private detective
they're great novels and he's got this
partner Joe pike my favourite fictional
character maybe of all time okay Joe
pike there's a former Marine Force Recon
guy that's a lot like your your friend
shock oh yeah and in the novels Joe pike
has a he's he always wears the same
outfit every day whereas jeans he wears
a sweatshirt the sleeves cut off and
aviator mirrored aviator sunglasses love
them already and and he's got bright red
arrows tattooed on his deltoids pointing
forward and basically his entire thing
is forward that's that's like feeling we
don't stop we don't slow down we don't
revisit bad you know past decisions we
don't we don't second-guess and so yeah
I actually honestly that question I have
no idea how to answer I think you just
did okay when you think of the word
successful who's the first person who
comes to mind and why oh that's a great
example it's a great that's a great
question honestly my father-in-law for
one who's the whole could be the subject
of a whole podcast oh so I guess can you
give us a taste of so I that is he's an
amazing guy John Chen re I got he is one
of the small handful of people who
basically built Silicon Valley and so he
he has an amazing life story but just to
do the short version is he went to
Stanford
he went to Stanford on a basketball
scholarship in the 1950s grew up very a
very very poor part of the country when
it's got a basketball scholarship
studied I got a bachelor's in geography
from Stanford you may have not ever in
your life met a lot of people who have a
bachelor's degree in geography
I've not they abolished the major the
year he mister greatest strong word he
became a real estate broker commercial
real estate broker in like 1958 when the
valley was all tortured within two years
he was making ten times more money
buying and developing properties as he
was as a broker and his boss fired him
because he was making all the other
brokers feel bad so he starting it's
basically continuously from 1960 to
today he's been one of the biggest
developers in Silicon Valley uniquely by
the way as far as I can tell uniquely
I've never met anybody else
for the first few years he basically he
has not used debts on a project I think
in almost 50 years so he's a real estate
developer who doesn't interact extremely
uncommon entirely on equity and and
basically it was he and there's a small
handful of him and his contemporaries
who basically built literally literally
built the valley and so ya know when I
wanna yeah he's he's great he's
fantastic I really love him he's
fantastic he um he once sat me down he's
like okay he's like you know he's like
this tech stuff I understand like you
guys think it's a big deal it's fine you
got you should go do it for now he's
just like I just want you to know the
real moneys in real estate yeah does
have a lot of street cred yes sir do you
have any particular morning rituals
important to you sleep in as long as
Boston as long as possible when you
usually wake up try not to blow through
any red lights a little bit work when
you usually wake up oh it 45 minutes
before I have my first meeting it's you
know it's I I do I do the what do they
call the hot docking I don't think it's
likely or the controlled crash into the
office
that's not ya know a you read these
videos all the afore teen things
successful people do in the morning like
I can't even imagine do you drink coffee
I drink it yeah I really think now the
perfect day is caffeine for 10 hours
alcohol for four like my day I'm not
sure I for a second about that this
Silicon Valley speedball yeah
do you've any favorite documentaries or
movies
[Music]
lots of favorite movies I don't know
where to start what have you seen
actually you know in the last 20 years
in last 10 years really you know it's TV
even where the movies okay what any
favorites well the whole we trainer so
mister robot which I just think is
absolute genius if you can ever guide
way getting you should get him some time
get the guy he's great Sam
yeah I I never met him probably right
about her time yeah so he's directing
he's written and he's personally
directing all 10 episodes of the new
season so it's gonna be I think he's
that he's he would be we went he has to
actually made a movie but like he's he's
definitely no win Oscars
as people win and then halt and catch
fire I'm not familiar that public catch
fire is extraordinary it's a very it's
the best fictional portrayal of what a
tech startup is actually like halt and
catch all and catch fire so there was a
it's a it's a title as there was a
mythic IDM mainframe days there was a
mythical instruction that it is sort of
a sort of an urban legend that there was
a specific piece of code that you could
write that would cause the computer to
stop and then catch on fire Mission
Impossible command yeah I don't think it
was ever really verified for sure
whether or not it existed but it kind of
became this mythical thing and so it's
it's the story actually it's loosely the
story of the birth of the PC and it
particularly it's sort of based on how
the company Compact got built in Houston
it's it's set in Texas but it's
basically the birth of a new computer
company but it's a very and it's they
say it's funny because the reviews the
reviews are fun so it's a historical
piece it's very serious serious drama so
you know it gets compared to Mad Men and
shows like that I said you know sat in
the office and the personal lives of
everybody and so and it's funny because
the the critics reviewed it and they
said I don't you know it all seems like
it all seems super heated like it's all
to like the melodrama is too exaggerated
of like all the stuff that happens and
everybody I know in the valley who's
seen is like no no that's actually what
it's like that's actually a hundred
percent what it's like and like I knew
that guy and I saw that thing happen and
I saw that person blow up that way it's
like Ben's book scene yeah exactly yeah
yeah it's what it's actually it's what
it's what so they they really caught the
it's fictionalized but they really for
anybody really wants to know what it's
ashli like to go through one of these
things that that shows tremendous and um
and then of course Silicon Valley yeah
do you have favorite scene or episode so
I'm actually still only seen the first
season I I'm not current I'm starting
actually become culturally irrelevant
cuz I can't I don't get any of any
references at all survive seem to be
doing just fine after I have to binge
the the sesame seed scene in the first
episode of the first season was probably
the highlight the the let's just say
loosely based on peter thiel scene
loosely or not or not very precisely
very accurately if you could have one
billboard anywhere with anything on it
what would you put on it
that could not be an advertisement for
when your portfolio companies outside
Trump Tower okay what would you put on
it if you wanted to convey a short
message to as many people as possible oh
I've got one all right maybe this is a
little maybe small scale for what you're
looking for but I've got one I've
actually thought about hiring a
skywriter to do this one let's do it
okay all right in the heart of San
Francisco big billboard just two words
on it raise prices raise prices yes can
you explain the number one thing just
the theme and we just see it everywhere
the number one theme of our companies
have and they get really struggling is
they they are not charging enough for
their product it has become absolutely
conventional wisdom is Silicon Valley
that the way to succeed is to price your
product as low as possible and then
under the theory that if it's low priced
everybody can buy it and that's how you
get to volume and we just see over and
over and over again people failing with
that because they because they get into
problem we call too hungry to eat they
don't charge enough for their product to
be able to afford the sales and
marketing required to actually get
anybody to buy it right and so they
can't hire the sales route they can't
afford to hire the sales rep to go sell
the product they can't afford to buy
that whatever TV commercial whatever it
is they can't afford they cannot afford
to go acquire the customers too hungry
to eat their 200 eat and then they sit
there they don't sell anything and then
they don't sell anything and they get
nervous and upset and then they cut the
prices and then it's a race to the
bottom which just makes the problem
worse and so probably the single number
one thing we try to get our companies to
do is like raise prices raise prices
Celeste and by the way yeah you know
it's like okay like is your product any
good if people won't pay more for it
exactly you know it's like a good litmus
test good litmus test right last two
questions what did you change your mind
about in the last few years that's a
good question so one is we started I'll
just give you a very practical one we
started on we started out we did we
didn't do any health care related stuff
your investments here and we've now done
a complete almost complete 180 on that
and we're now very deep into health
because we think a bunch of really
interesting things are happening and
that was a response
she's like the headphone thing I was
telling husband like that was respond we
just we just basically had a very smart
founders coming through here basically
telling us we were dumb like and by the
way they were right like we just haven't
figured it out yet
and so we got serious about it a couple
years ago and we have this guy vijay
pundit from so former Stanford professor
running this program
it's extraordinary what's happening at
the kind of intersection of healthcare
and computer science so there's a lot
that's happening there the thing that
I'm probably think about the most that I
am still trying to work out in my own
head is that a combination of Peter
Thiel Larry Page and Elon Musk in
different ways have provoked a
fundamental crisis a fundamental law
conversation of the valley around you
know kind of that sort of moonshots the
big the big the big the big the the big
challenges and so you know any line you
know why can't we build self-driving
cars why can't we have new kinds of
rocket ships why can't we go to like
literally go to Mars why can't we cure
cancer why can't we you know do nuclear
fusion
why can't you know long list of things
that are like you know big big things we
talked about earlier a little bit like
Silicon Valley has always viewed itself
a little bit the tools business all
right or a lot the tools business
Silicon Valley has been getting more and
more assertive entering more and more
industries directly right so like uber
lyft entering directly into
transportation Airbnb entering directly
into real estate FinTech companies
entering directly into banking so our
companies are getting more assertive at
going into markets that previously they
may not you know other founders may not
have been willing to go into in the past
and then Larry Elon and Peter basically
all say in different ways like we're
still not doing enough there are these
much bigger things to be to be done and
why are we waiting for either
government's to do them or for large
industrial companies like GE to do them
or for you know I don't know research
universities to figure them out like why
can't we do these things and you know
there's one school of thought that says
they're simply too hard there's simply
too hard they're too daunting they're
too expensive they're too different you
know they're they don't have Moore's law
on their side like they're there there's
a reason we haven't been doing that was
because they're they're too difficult
and then there's another school of
thought that says you know that's just
being a wimp and you should go try to do
all these things because if we're not
gonna do it really who is and then I'm
trying to find is there something in the
middle like is there like what are the
shades of grey
mm-hmm right what's what's the line
right what's what's the line where you
know Tevlin what's line where Tesla made
sense but you know Tesla Tesla that
flies didn't make sense like right and
there's a line in there somewhere
I think right or maybe Peters right and
maybe there isn't a line and maybe and
maybe maybe the next
should be one the flies right and so
it's to me that's the provocative think
is it's a question about stretching the
limits how far caress myth how far can
we stretch the limits of what we're
wings know before our wings melt right
and it strikes me also that I mean did
you mention Peters so I the we wanted
flying cars and we got 140 characters it
there were a lot of questions from from
fans asking how to how would he suggest
people entrepreneurs are be encouraged
to say they solve the big problems
versus making social media networks etc
and I think you made point actually in a
debate with Peter at one point maybe as
the Milken conference could've been
elsewhere that Twitter and I would agree
with you as one example 140 characters
has been world-changing in a lot of ways
I mean you look at political activism
you look at many different examples when
you have adoption that that that is that
wide that global free with the emergent
properties are just unpredictable I mean
you get some incredible use cases
including political revolutions exactly
right yeah last so that was it was a
debate at the Milken conference which is
one of my one of my shining moments is I
prepared for weeks for that debate yeah
knowing Peter wasn't gonna prepare at
all yeah they bring that up because I
think I was actually able to go
toe-to-toe with him but III had to
sandbag him to do it
um he was absolutely shocked that I had
refer I enjoyed think I really enjoyed
was might one of my grandma my great
debating moments as I could I could
almost keep up with Peter um so it's
actually funny his whole thing his whole
slogan that you know the slogan of his
firm which is this you said we were
promised flying cars instead we got 140
characters especially interesting he
will immediately concede but that both
of those are actually not the point so
he first of all he immediately concedes
the flying cars probably don't make
sense and then he immediately concedes
that Twitter probably is more important
than like just being dismissed like that
and so he will he basically just
basically says the slogan it was just to
provoke provoke the conversation mmm-hmm
but to your point it does provoke the
conversation and I actually think you're
I think you're right I think it provokes
a conversation from both sides which is
okay why don't we have the other bigot
maybe flying cars are not well why don't
we have nuclear fusion why don't we have
like all these other things why don't we
have supersonic flight right like we
have the Concorde
now we don't even have a Concorde like
seriously it takes nine hours to get to
London like really
right I mean I think that's it's it's a
very relevant question and then but I
also think it provokes the thing on the
other side which is I think the computer
stuff communication stuff like Twitter
and all these other things if I meter
flatly says the iPhone doesn't count as
innovation and I just think that's I
think that's too far right I think it
absolutely causes innovation I think
it's one of the most important products
ever developed I think the impact on the
world is absolutely enormous and growing
and so I think there's there's a there's
a tendency to write off the stuff that
built the valley and I don't think I
don't agree with that I think there's a
lot more to do in the core of what we do
the last question is do you have any any
ask or request of my audience people
listening anything you'd like them to
consider ponder do so first of all they
should all for sure work for our
companies please come to our website a
16z comm we have jobs we have job
listings we'd like to get everybody in
our orbit anybody smart enough to listen
to your podcast we definitely want to
work for our companies and then you know
I would say you know I would say build
new things and then if it's something
that needs if it's a you know for the
business that's promising that needs
money you know we're open for we're open
for business
mark any last places you'd like people
to check you out online where can they
say hello Oh Twitter Twitter's good
Twitter's got Twitter that's he @p marca
peppy markup EMA are that from your UNIX
handle way back in the day it's an old
old joke it's a boss one time who was so
important that he had both his real you
yet its public email address and he has
P with his name behind it which is his
private email address that was a little
bit too much and so we all gave
ourselves P nobody knew who we work
perfectly well everybody say I check out
the intrusion Horowitz website I'll put
that in the show notes as well you
should also check out their podcast
which I guess greatly enjoyed there's
that you can start with I mean one that
I really enjoyed was the sort of
deconstructing Amazon episode and thank
you so much for the time work this has
been blast I really appreciate it thanks
to him and to everyone listening can to
find all the links and everything else
in the show notes which you can find a
four hour workweek comm forward slash
podcast and until next time thank you
for listening this episode is brought to
you by 99designs 99designs is a great
partner for creating and growing your
business it
a one-stop shop for all of your graphic
design needs whether that's a logo
website business card or anything else I
use 99 designs to get cover prototypes
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one New York Times best
seller I also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs designers around the world to
compete to create the best design for
you you give feedback and then pick your
favorite you end up happy or you get
your money back it's very simple you can
check out a few of my own designs and
those of yours meaning Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs calm /if Tim and
right now my listeners you guys will get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design
that's 99 designs dot-com forward slash
Tim check it out this episode is brought
to you by audible which I've used for
years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is perhaps my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by Rolf pots which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books the
graveyard book vagabonding or more than
180,000 audio programs so that could be
a book that could be a magazine that can
be a newspaper it could be a class it's
that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible.com forward
slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
you